Speaker 1: if like me. You've been skeptical
that Joe Biden's declining approval rating
is actually because of the Afghanistan
fiasco, which I believe is the right decision
but has had significant tragedy within it, I
believe you are completely correct. It is not
because of Afghanistan that Joe Biden's approval
rating started to decline. And today, I want to
talk about why Joe Biden's approval rating is
actually declining. Now, before we do that,
the first question is, has Joe Biden's approval
rating declined? Never assume, right? I mean,
so if the story is, why is it declined? First,
let's verify whether it has declined. It has
declined. The answer is yes. Joe Biden's approval
started around the mid 50s in an average of polls
when he took office. It was in the low 50s around
mid-June. It is now down to an average of 47.
And Joe Biden has switched to a net disapproval,
net disapproval. More people disapproving than
approving that is a decline and it's outside the
margin of error. But Afghanistan is playing a role
only recently in this. And part of why we know
that that's true is we understand how time works.
The decline for Joe Biden's approval started
in late July. That was reflective, therefore,
because it takes a couple of days to put together
the polling data and release it. And it's based
on what happened before that, because Joe Biden's
approval rating started declining publicly in late
July, it means it was based on what was going on
in mid-July. The Afghanistan situation didn't take
place in mid-July. It took place in mid-August. So
because time moves forward and we don't currently
have time machines that I'm aware of, something
other than Afghanistan started this decline in
Joe Biden's approval. So what is it? Why is it
that Joe Biden's approval is declining? There
are a number of reasons. First, it is typical that
presidents come into office with higher approval
and then it goes down. That's really common.
Why is that? Well, the way a lot of people think
is not when asked, do I approve of the
way Joe Biden is handling being president?
Most people don't say, well, I agree with
eight out of 10 things he's done. So I approve.
Many people think if there is anything
he's done that I don't like, I disapprove.
And so over time, you typically see presidential
approval ratings decline. There are instances
that are different when 9/11 happened. George
W. Bush's approval shot up. He then squandered
it by attacking the wrong country. OK, but it
is typical that presidency declining approval
during their presidency. So that's a systemic
reality. Now, in terms of what was happening,
Joe Biden's decline in approval coincided with the
covid Delta variant search. Biden's high approval
early in his term was riding on being new, but
also on declining case numbers and on rapidly
accelerating vaccination. Thanks to anti vaccines
and the Delta variant covid is now exploding.
Hospitalizations are at record. Vaccinations have
slowed down, although lately they are picking back
up. And Biden's approval decline came right as
the case numbers went up in late June and early
July. Now, in addition, Joe Biden started to
really need a big legislative accomplishment.
I've been talking about this with you for a couple
of months and he has not gotten it. This has put
more downward pressure on Joe Biden's approval.
And then after months of all of this stuff,
yes, Afghanistan imploded. And even though it
was not only the correct decision to leave,
but one that most Americans support, the chaotic
fallout pushed Biden's approval down, further
accelerated by negative coverage of what was
going on in Afghanistan now. I also believe.
That Joe Biden's approval is going to
go lower before it recovers, if it does,
because the latest polling is mostly from before
the ISIS suicide bombing in Kabul about five days
ago, I imagine that Joe Biden's approval is going
to get down to the low 40s before it might start
to recover. That's if there's a recovery. We
don't know yet. Now, even though Afghanistan
is currently hurting Joe Biden in the polling, I
don't think that Afghanistan will be a factor in
twenty, twenty two. It's a guess. It's still
possible. But I believe that the combination
of short voter memory, combined with foreign
policy, simply not impacting elections very much,
particularly midterm elections, combined with
it being Democrats up for reelection in 2002,
not Joe Biden himself. I would be surprised if
Afghanistan plays a major role in the midterm
elections that are now just about, what is it, 15,
14 months away? I actually think that it's wackier
to blame Delta on Biden, which started the
decline in his approval, then Afghanistan. Delta
rose globally and in some places like the U.S.,
it's really bad. Why is it so bad? Well, because
of the anti AXA's who are mostly Republican,
because of Republican governors who states are
not doing well now. I agree that the buck stops
with Biden. It does. But the truth is, Biden
scaled up vaccination. Biden did most things right
on the virus, but Republicans called it fascism.
And Republican governors tried to block
many of the things that Joe Biden was doing,
blamed Biden for things that are truly his
fault or at least a result of what he's done.
But we know that that's not how politics
actually works. So, bottom line,
I'm expecting a continued decline in approval
for Joe Biden before it levels out. But I
don't expect Afghanistan to play a major
role in the twenty, twenty two midterms.
If you disagree with me or you agree or you're
confused or you don't even know where you are,
you can find me on Twitter at David Pakman and let
me know your thoughts. My friends, I would love it
if you signed up at joined Pakman Dotcom and
became a The David Pakman Show member today.
It is our primary source of funding. We want to
be primarily funded by the audience. And you can
get instant access to the daily bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Pakman Dotcom